all right so if you guys remember on the
subject of the immortals me and one of
my fellow YouTube personality types had
a bit of a disagreement about it here's
something I definitely want to see that
week and that's the Immortals
that is like the cool version of Clash
of the Titans
I hope it's cold I may be proven wrong
but this looks like the 300 movie that's
not 300 mixed with Clash of the Titans
they're trying again now we get to see
who's right
immortals are so the immortal stars
henry cavill I heard his name's
pronounced differently than Koval but
I'm gonna call him Koval because that's
how it's spelled and it's a story like a
lot of these Greek gods stories are
drive yourself immortal he's been chosen
by the gods now he's got to save the
world who has he got to save the world
from well Mickey Rourke of course
because Mickey Rourke is just bad he was
so bad Mickey Rourke makes Genghis Khan
straight-up look like Chaka Khan that
was good and Mickey Rourke is going
after this bow that can free the Titans
and this bows awesome you saw it in the
trailer where you pull it backwards all
boom like blows everyone should have a
boat like that and so now Henry Cavill
the hot chick you know Slumdog
Millionaire his girlfriend and steaming
door for all going after this bow to
save the world the first half of it
feels like you've seen movies like this
a hundred times over and the writing
feels kind of sloppy if it's not sloppy
it's just not special but the second
half is a lot cooler than that like you
see these scenes in the trailer where
just these grand things are happening
cuz these gods are doing awesome [ __ ]
those scenes are in the movie but
there's like three of them in the entire
movie so if you go into this movie
hoping for that stuff don't don't do
that you're gonna be disappointed are
those scenes cool yeah when it happens
you're like oh yeah the gods should
metal all the time however most of the
movie is about three or four people
going after Mickey Rourke now in the
second half of this movie Henry Cavill
shows us why he is the Superman he has
this speech you know one of those
William Wallace type speeches all the
costume pictures of Superman don't mean
anything to me but when you stand up on
a ledge and you start throwing down
those you know freedom and fight for
honor and glory and all that good [ __ ]
Superman we salute you and in the last
thread under the movie some more cool
[ __ ] happens but it looks kind of fake
too like it's cool-looking but again
you're like EDS it's still kind of fake
it's cool fake if cool fake had a term
it would be the end of this movie this
movie has moments of really great
director doesn't change the fact that
I'm not going to rush back to see it the
rest of the movie just kind of feels
like some director was like hey I'm the
director of the cell and I want to make
any mortals
of it this movies okay but have
sprinkled mixtures of like great in it
in the end as a whole the movie comes
out to just being okay I would say watch
immortals
if you're drunk en as a party one Queen
song been a while since I've given that
writing when I'm on the fence about a
movie that has a lot of special effects
that's the one it gets cuz it's cool so
in the Jeremy versus Christian battle of
is immortals dog [ __ ] are great it's not
dog [ __ ] and in that I apologize I guess
I was wrong however in the scale of
great movie and bad movie I was more
right than wrong and that's my apology
and I'm sticking to it so your favorite
story movie book heck even game about
Greek gods what is it comment below let
me know yeah there's going to be one
game that's going to be mentioned here
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more